في الجزائر في ظاهره شاغله الناس من
اسابيع وعامله حاله من القلق ففي بوستات
على المنصات واخبار بتقول انه تلاميذ في
المرحله الابتدائيه بيتعرضوا لوخس بئر في
محيط المدرسه ومو معروف مين بيعمل كده
اولاد وجلست الاخبار متداوله هنا وزاره
العدل اصدرت بيان اعلنت في رصد خمس حالات
وخز لتلاميذ بابر في محيط مدارسهم كلهم
كان الوقت في يدهم اليسرى واللي بياخذهم
كانوا الستات واعلنت السلطات بانها بتبحث
وبتحقق في الموضوع ومين وراءه وطلبت من
الاهالي تنبيه اولادهم انهم يبعدوا عن اي
غريب يقرب منهم بعدها بكم يوم طلع خبر عن
محاوله اختطاف سيدتين لتلميذات في محيط
المدرسه ولقيوا معاهم ابر واعترفوا بسلطهم
مشعوذه معروفه وانقبض عليهم كلهم
[تصفيق]
بعد هذا الاعلان وصور الابر هذه الناس
قالت خلاص بانت الموضوع السحر وشعوذه وناس
تقول لا هذه محاولات خطف الدرج الوطني طلع
وهدى الناس وقال لهم انه بيعملوا كل ما في
وسعهم لضمان امنهم ودعاهم للتبليغ عن اي
حالات جديده وتجنب التهويل ونشر الدور
[موسيقى]